[Music]
hi I'm Jenny and I love horror movies it
doesn't even really matter to me what
subgenre they are or what era they come
from though of course I have preferences
in that regard just give me some ghost
choked castles some unspeakable monsters
some taboo breaking imagery Andor
gallons of dripping
and I am a happy Crystal Lake camper as
a matter of fact if someone wanted to
pay me to do it please I would happily
and gladly watch horror movies all day
every day and never get tired of them
until the day I Dro dead there's just
something so fundamentally me about the
horror genre that I don't think that I
could ever extricate myself from the
hold that it has over me even if I
wanted to which I don't to be perfectly
clear so for a long time I'd been
wanting to do kind of an extended video
delving into the history of horror
movies and talking about some of my
favorite examples from every decade now
it's taken me this long to get around to
it as you can see but better late than
never so at long last let's do
[Applause]
this horror as an overriding genre of
course didn't start with movies humans
have been fascinated by scary things
since before they were even humans and
some of the oldest written tales in
existence contain massive dollops of
horrific situations and monstrous
creatures everything from the Epic of
gilgames to the Greek and Roman myths to
the Holy Bible contains Fantastical
Critters people being killed in terrible
ways people possessed by demons or
turning into vampires or werewolves and
folks coming back from the dead the real
world is a frightening place after all
and by couching realworld Horrors within
fictional ones we can better get a
handle on our anxieties about the
Dreadful Fates that may one day befall
us this is true the world over and thus
every culture has its own darker
mythologies and specific
[Music]
Boogeyman in the 19th century there was
something of an explosion in horror
themed literary content though it wasn't
named or marketed as such at the time
usually being termed Gothic Instead The
Works of Anne Radcliffe Horus Walpole
Sheridan lefanu Henry James Mary Shelly
Bram Stoker and Edgar Allen Poe would
focus on death Despair and Supernatural
themes and in fact it was many of these
very works that served as Source
material for the developing media of
film when it was still in its
infancy the first horror film if it
could be called that is generally
considered to be 1896s l manoir d diab
The House of the devil released in the
US at as the haunted castle directed by
prolific aour George melaz the film
itself is only a few minutes long and is
really more funny than scary utilizing
many trick shots and special effects
that were all the rage at the time but
it does contain a decrepit old castle
bats skeletons and the devil manifesting
witchy ladies and imps out of a big ass
cauldron melia's made a few of these
short trick films with vaguely
Supernatural or horror esque themes
including the nightmare from 1896 the
Bewitched Inn from 1897 and the Cave of
the Demons from 1898 he made a [__] ton
of other movies too I mean it's fairly
easy to make 70 odd movies a year when
they're only a couple minutes long but
most of them weren't horror so we
needn't concern ourselves with them here
suffice it to say that George melia's
was an enormous influence not only on
horror films but on film history in
general the early years of the 20th
century saw a ridiculous number of
horror flicks being churned out as
filmmakers began capitalizing on and
experimenting with this new and exciting
technology and if you think the modern
movie making landscape is bad because of
the seemingly endless cycles of remakes
and sequels allow me to direct your
attention to the earliest days of Cinema
when one single year could see multiple
separate movie adaptations of say Oscar
Wild's The Picture of Dorian Gray or
robbert lewi Stevenson's The Strange
Case of Dr Jackal and Mr Hyde even
Thomas Edison got in on the ACT cranking
out a weird adaptation of Mary Shell's
Frankenstein in
1910 most of these movies were pretty
short but the first multi- horror film
was also a literary adaptation a creepy
1911 film version of Dante's
Inferno there were a whole bunch of Po
adaptations as well particularly in
France and in the United States
including 1909s the sealed room which
was not so much a direct adaptation as a
sort of inspired by deal you also had
1912s The Raven and 1913s the Pit and
the Pendulum one of my favorite films
from the silent era as a matter of fact
was a hypnotic expressionist adaptation
of The Fall of the House of Usher though
that didn't come out until 1928 it had
some utterly outstanding visuals
though keep in mind that at this stage
horror wasn't really codified as a
discreet genre that anyone would
recognize though some films would
occasionally be described using that
term most of the movies as I mentioned
were adapted from existing literature or
mythology an example of that latter idea
would be Paul Wagner's the Golem from
1915 based around a type of monster from
Jewish folklore only clips of the Golem
and its dark comedy sequel the Golem and
the dancing girl from 1917 remain but
the third installment 1920s the Golem
how he came into the world still exists
in its
entirety
[Music]
by the time the 1920s dawned it was all
about German expressionism baby and the
style came busting right out of the
oddly shaped gate with The Surreal and
dreamlike 1920 movie The Cabinet of Dr
Caligari expressionism's whole purpose
was to use images as exteriorized
manifestations of a character's inner
turmoil and since Francis the character
in Caligari who is telling us the story
in flashback turns out to be an inmate
at an insane asum spoiler alert for a
century old movie the entire film plays
out against a bizarre nightmarish
backdrop of Stark Shadows Twisted
buildings and absolutely no right angles
a grim fantasmagorical Vision meant to
signify francis's unstable mental state
the look of this movie is so [__]
cool that it almost single-handedly
influenced the visual style of the
iconic Universal monster movies that
would come along a decade later and
anyone who's a fan of Tim Burton's films
will immediately see where he got a lot
of his aesthetic flare as
well as far as the 1920s go the other
heavy hitter of horror was of course
1922s NOS veratu directed by FW mnau and
starring Max Shrek as the vampire count
orlock the movie is a Dracula adaptation
in all but name Ram Stoker's Widow
famously wouldn't give manau permission
to adapt the novel so the German
director tried to do an end run around
her by
essentially making a straight Dracula
movie but just changing the names of the
characters a little bit nice try but of
course it didn't work stoker sued she
won and the judge ordered all copies of
NOS veratu destroyed luckily for
posterity at least a few lonely little
copies survived somewhere and now more
than a century later we can still watch
This creepy ass flick in all its spooky
Glory Max Shrek really steals the show
here I have to say and his appearance is
so so unsettling and inhuman that many
years later in 2000 e Elias mahes of
begotten Fame would make a terrific
little film called shadow of the vampire
in which he presented the idea that mow
played by John malovich had hired an
actual blood sucker played by William
Defoe to play the part of count orlock
in the movie perhaps even more so than
the cabinet of do Caligari nus veratu
would set the standard for the
burgeoning horror genre going forward
and as such its importance can't be
overstated as you might have noticed a
lot of the really influential horror at
this point was coming from Europe but
America certainly had its moments as
well though the days of big horror stars
like B Lugosi and Boris carloff were
still a few years away Hollywood did
have Lon Cheney the man of a thousand
faces who starred in loads of different
kinds of films but is today remembered
most fondly for his more horror tinged
turns in the Hunchback of notredam from
from 1923 and the Phantom of the Opera
from 1925 roles for which he designed
and executed his own extraordinary
makeup that still looks fantastic today
Lan Cheney also starred in one of the
most famous lost horror films of the
silent era 1927's London after midnight
directed by Todd Browning just the
Stills alone are creepy as hell and I'm
really hoping this movie gets Unearthed
in my lifetime because I would love to
see
it some of my other favorite horror
films films from the 1920s that I
haven't mentioned yet would include the
Phantom Carriage
hexan the hands of
orlac and The Man Who Laughs which
incidentally was a huge influence on the
look of the Joker from the Batman
[Applause]
comics the 1930s would be a watershed
decade for horror as the genre would
become its own recognized Niche and
produce a handful of iconic Act actors
and films that are still revered to this
day the aforementioned Todd Browning
ushered in the Golden Age of the
universal monsters with his 1931 Dracula
starring Hungarian actor Baya Lugosi who
had played the role in the Broadway
stage version since
1927 lugosi's portrayal of the count
differed significantly from the
character in Stoker's novel who was more
in line with the way he was represented
in no veratu indeed I think it's pretty
fair to say that b legosi's
interpretation of the character has had
the most impact on the way we perceive
vampires in media today in Vampire
folklore the monster was almost always a
disgusting ghoul in a bloody shroud but
Lugosi made him a smooth handsome
alluring nobleman think about it if you
go to a Halloween store and look for a
classic vampire costume it's going to
look like what Lugosi wore in the play
in the movie and if you ask someone to
put on that costume and act like a
vampire odds are very good that they'll
start doing lugosi's thck Hungarian
accent that right there is cultural
indelibility
I'd like to mention here that during
this era Studios would sometimes film a
Spanish language version of whatever
movie they had going they'd use the same
script and the same sets but all
different actors this was the case for
Universal's Dracula as well and I'll
note that the Spanish version of the
movie directed by George mford is
absolutely worth watching and in some
respects is superior to the American
version in my opinion at least in
regards to its more Dynamic shot
compositions and longer runtime allowing
more of the intricacies of the novel to
appear on
screen anyway Dracula was a big hit with
both critics and audiences and Universal
figured they were onto a lucrative thing
with this horror business so they
decided to strike while the iron was hot
immediately planning adaptations of
Frankenstein and Po's murders in the
room org B legosi was famously offered
the role of the monster in the upcoming
Frankenstein film film but turned it
down because the role had no dialogue
and he didn't like the idea of his face
being covered in heavy makeup and
Prosthetics the role was instead awarded
to a relatively little known character
actor by the name of Boris carof and His
stunning sympathetic but also pretty
scary performance as well as Jack
Pierce's iconic makeup design ensured
the movie's wild success and
unbelievable staying
power both Lugosi and carof were now
major Stars was a hot genre and
Universal kept cranking out more spooky
flicks for an eager public carof
returned to the screen in 1932's the
mummy a film that very much took the
bones of the Dracula story and placed it
in an Egyptian context the makeup in
that film also by Jack Pierce is
likewise incredible and although carof
is only actually in the rap to Mummy get
up for a tiny portion of the film he's
so great as the more human sorcerer
character arith Bay that you won't even
mind and the later sequels none of which
starred carof would feature way more of
a wrapped mummy rampaging plot so check
those out if that's more your
speed the two legends would also star in
a bunch of movies together during the
1930s including the amazing 1934 film
The Black Cat very Loosely based on the
Edgar Allen Poe story sort of and
another po adaptation 1935's The Raven
Universal would put out a bunch of
horror titles with different actors too
like the old dark house from 1932 Direct
Ed by James whale who also helmed
Frankenstein and 1933 is the Invisible
Man starring Claude Reigns also 1935 saw
the release of whale's followup to
Frankenstein Bride of Frankenstein
starring Elsa Lanchester which many
people believe is superior to the
original I'm not actually sure where I
fall on that I really like them both so
it's almost like having to pick your
favorite
kid meanwhile the other Studios saw how
much cash Universal was raking in with
these newfangled scary pictures and
started throwing their hats into the
ring for example MGM made their own
great adaptation of Dr Jackal and Mr
Hyde in 1931 Paramount made island of
Lost Souls based on HG Wells novel The
Island of Dr Moro in 1932 and Warner
Brothers released mystery of the wax
museum in
1933 but among all the other Studios RKO
would be the one to unleash another of
the most important movie Monsters onto
the world with their 1933 film FM King
Kong bolstered by the stupendous
stopmotion effects of Willis O'Brien the
movie was a smashing success spawning a
number of sequels offshoots and reboots
over the years right up until the
present
day aside from all the excellent and
important horror movies that came out
during the 1930s the other significant
development of the decade unfortunately
was the so-called Haze code because some
Pearl clutching nines somewhere believed
that seeing vampire Ires stalking busty
young ladies and mad scientists bringing
corpses back to life would Decay the
morals of society at large or something
a sort of self-censorship agreement was
established that drastically limited
what you could show in a movie from 1934
all the way up to 1968 when it was
replaced by the MPAA rating system we're
all familiar with today the UK had a
similar censorship thing going on and in
fact it was their reluctance to show
American horror movies in WR that led to
Hollywood Studios making fewer horror
flicks starting in
1936 the genre wouldn't stay down for
long however and by the end of the 1930s
both Dracula and Frankenstein were
re-released kicking off another string
of sequels and increasing the genre's
popularity once
[Applause]
again the early years of the 1940s
before the US entry into World War II
were all about trading on beloved horror
properties and as such Universal release
movies like 1940s The Invisible Man
Returns 1941's the mummy's hand 1942's
ghost of Frankenstein and 1943's Son of
Dracula arguably the most important
Universal film to come out in these
years was 1941's The Wolf Man which
established another of the classic
monsters we still recognize today the
film starred Lon Cheney Jr as the doomed
Larry talbet and Universal was very keen
to make him their next big horror star
placing him in several of the
aforementioned films playing Dracula
Frankenstein's monster and the mummy Lan
Cheney Jr in fact is the horror actor
who played more of the classic monsters
than anyone else four of them to be
precise with the only emissions being
the Invisible Man and the Creature from
the Black Lagoon which came out much
later
anyway since the monsters were so
popular Universal started doing all
kinds of fun crossovers with them such
as 1943 3's Frankenstein meets The Wolf
Man and 1945's House of Dracula these
pictures came to be known as Monster
mashes or Monster rallies there were
also a host of smaller Studios like
monogram or PRC looking to ape Universal
success and putting out their own lower
budget flicks sometimes they even got
bigname horror actors like Baya Lugosi
to star in their poverty row quickies if
said actors needed some Ready
Cash RKO makers of King Kong were also
looking to get into the lowbudget horror
film business and set up a new sideline
headed by producer Val Luton the funny
thing was that the studio would give
Luton a splashy title and expect him to
come up with some lurid cheapy that
would get butts and seats but Luton
decided to go classy with it and make
more sophisticated psychological Fair
case in point was his wonderful 1942
film cat people which I'm sure the
studio heads were envisioning to be a
sexy lady version of the The Wolf Man
complete with a hot babe transforming
into a cat but Luton instead turned this
general idea into a fascinating
ambiguous and beautifully shot drama
about a woman who supposedly transforms
into a black panther when sexually
aroused or jealous Luton also made
another of the best horror films of the
1940s I walked with a zombie from
1943 as the decade went on there was
more of an emphasis on this kind of
psychological horror as the movie
audiences had started to skew noticeably
older Alfred Hitchcock made Spellbound
in 1945 and the awesome film the spiral
staircase came out a year later much
like today though these films were
generally referred to as Thrillers
rather than horror movies even though
they absolutely had horror elements it
seems that audiences and critics were
still associating the horror tag with
rampaging monsters and supernatural
creatures rather than villainous human
antagonists when the United States
became involved in the second world war
theater attendance declined
precipitously and it seemed as though
the public taste for horror films took a
particular hit as very few of them were
made in the latter part of the 1940s
though several of the classics were
re-released During the period I've heard
a lot of experts theorize that this was
probably because people were
experiencing real Horrors in their lives
and didn't have any desire to see fake
ones I don't know if that's true though
it sounds fairly reasonable I guess it's
always seemed to me that eras featuring
a lot of Social and cultural upheaval
tend to produce the best horror films as
artists are working out their own
anxieties through fiction but it's
possible that the specific anxieties
engendered by the war all came out in
the movies of the following decade of
the
[Music]
1950s although there were a few St
strling Gothic horror films that came
out in the early 1950s like 1952's the
black castle with Boris carof and 1953's
House of Wax with Vincent Price the
general perception in Hollywood was that
all those creaky old classic monsters
were pretty p a and by this time the
iconic horror stars of the golden era
were mostly starting to age out a bit
bosi in particular seemed to have the
hardest time shedding his typ casting
and ended up a drug addict who was
compelled to appear in no budget schlock
like that put out by the likes of Edwood
not that edwood's movies aren't
entertaining because they are but
they're entertaining largely because
they're so
terrible that said the classic monsters
didn't disappear from the cinema
landscape entirely but their stories
were retooled to fit into the more
sci-fi framework that was the Hallmark
of the
era science fiction was the trending sub
genre in the 1950s and movies went all
in with themes of science gone wrong in
Alien invasions Christian NES 1951 the
thing from another world based on the
Nolla who goes there by John W Campbell
and of course remade by John Carpenter
in 1982 as the thing was one of the most
influential films of the era and spawned
an enormous number of similar flicks
about nefarious
extraterrestrials such as it came from
outer space and Invaders from Mars both
of those from
1953 Invasion of the Body Snatchers from
1956 and it the Terror from Beyond Space
from
1958 there was also it should be noted a
classic flick with a sympathetic helpful
alien visitor 1951's The Day the Earth
Stood Still but this was a rarer theme
amid the era's growing paranoia due to
the Cold
War other mini trends of the 1950s
included the so-called big bug movies
The Best of which was them from 1954
about giant ants but there was also It
Came from Beneath the sea from 1955
about a big ass octopus tarantula from
1956 the deadly mantis from
1957 Beginning of the End also from 1957
about swarms of giant Locust Earth
versus the spider from 1958 the giant
heila monster from 1959 and attack of
the Giant Leeches also from
1959 these films inevitably gave
radiation as the reason for the animals
growing to such alarming proportions
thus revealing the culture's overriding
unease with the burgeoning nuclear arms
race and the threat of creeping
communism and Annihilation under a
mushroom cloud radiation was also
responsible for easily the most enduring
monster of the 1950s good old Godzilla
whose first film rampaged out of Japan
in 1954 and started a franchise that's
still crushing buildings underfoot in
the 21st
century a brief craze for 3D films also
came and went in the first few years of
the dec decade and the latter half of
the 1950s saw the fleeting but glorious
trend of the gimmick film mostly
propounded by director William Castle
The Tingler and the House on Haunted
Hill both from 1959 and both starring
Vincent Price featured some fun things
going on live in the theater where the
movies were playing The Tingler for
example which was about a kind of
centipede looking parasite that lived in
people's spinal columns and caused fear
but could be dislodged by screaming had
a mimic whereby theater showing it would
rig up some seats with buzzers that
would replicate a tingling sensation
down Patron's backs there was also a
sequence in the movie Where The Tingler
got loose in a movie theater and the
movie itself would go black with the
voiceover on the film urging everyone in
the audience to scream to frighten The
Tingler Away by the same token House on
Haunted Hill boasted something called
emero which was in reality just a
glow-in-the-dark skeleton that would
come out from behind the screen on a
wire and fly over the audience's heads
during the climax of the
film there was also a growing
recognition of the Teen subculture and
Studios were quick to capitalize
releasing stuff like I was a teenage
werewolf and I was a teenage
Frankenstein both from
1957 there were also lowbudget flicks
like teenagers from outer space from
1959 which featured some teenagers in
their late 30s who came to Earth dressed
in unflattering jumpsuits and were
looking for a safe place to arm their
giant pet lobsters and no I did not just
make that
up I'd also be remiss if I didn't point
out that hammer film Productions also
came into their own during the 1950s in
the first part of the decade they
focused mainly on black and white
science fiction films much like their
American counterparts but in 1957 they
decided to go back in time and revisit
some of the universal Monsters of old
but in saturated color and with much
more Gore and semi nudity the curse of
Frankenstein from 1957 and Dracula from
1958 which was released as the Horror of
Dracula in the US came out of the gate
swinging not only introducing two new
horror icons in the forms of Peter
Cushing and Christopher Lee but
simultaneously updating the gothic
monsters for a new generation a business
model that would bring the studio great
returns for years to
[Applause]
come the 1960s was the decade that
changed changed everything in regard to
horror movies as it changed so many
other things
culturally 1960 saw the release of two
films that served as something of a
precursor to the slasher films of later
years Michael Powell's peeping Tom and
of course Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
which was based on the novel by Robert
block which in turn was very Loosely
based on real Wisconsin grave robber and
murderer Ed
G there had been movies about serial
killers before Fritz Lang's M from from
1931 and Charles lon's the Knight of the
hunter from 1955 spring to mind but they
had mostly turned up in Thrillers or
film Noir and their psychology hadn't
really been deeply
explored the fact that both psycho and
peeping Tom featured Killers who were
initially sympathetic to the audience
was pretty novel and probably went a
long way toward explaining why peeping
Tom in particular was considered So
Scandalous by British audiences that it
essentially ruined Michael Powell's
career
Alfred Hitchcock of course suffered no
such dire repercussions though psycho
itself was quite controversial upon
release not least because of its
violence which is only cleverly implied
and not graphically shown the fact that
the ostensible protagonist was a thief
who was shown in bed with a man she
wasn't married to and the further
Revelation that this supposedly main
character played by Janet Lee gets
murdered less than halfway through the
story the movie is still a compelling
watch to this day specifically due to
its outstanding lead performance by
Anthony Perkins and I'd also argue that
the sequels are way better than they
have any right to be particularly psycho
2 from
1983 psycho is another movie whose
impact on the genre is akin to an atom
bomb in fact many experts have stated
that the horror film genre can be neatly
divided into two distinct categories
movies before psycho and movies after
psycho because the 1960s was such a
tumultuous era filmmakers seem to be
pushing envelopes all over the place
experimenting with taboo subjects and
testing the limits of what could be
portrayed on screen 1960 was also
notable for the release of the excellent
French film Eyes Without a Face an eerie
drama about a disfigured woman whose mad
scientist father keeps killing girls in
order to graft their faces onto hers the
movie includes a scene where the doctor
very dispassionately slices the skin of
a girl 's face with a scalpel and peels
the whole thing off and even though the
movie is in black and white and looks
somewhat tamed by today's standards I
can imagine that audiences in 1960 were
probably horrified to the point of
fainting Italian Maestro Mario Bava also
upped the antee with his black and white
witchcraft tale black Sunday starring
Barbara steel the film was far more
violent than almost anything else
audiences had seen up to that point and
the opening sequence were a spiked Iron
Mask is nailed onto a woman's face was
especially shocking for the time Bava
would go on to craft another
ultraviolent Masterpiece 1964's blood
and black lace a Galo film that was a
major influence on later horror legends
Dario Argento and Lucho
fuli Baba's particular blend of
eroticism and horror would also be
mirrored in the 60s era films of other
European directors like Spaniards Jess
Franco and Paul nashy and Frenchmen Jean
Rollin meanwhile back in the United
States a Pittsburgh filmmaker named
Hershel Gordon Lewis decided to go much
much further than anyone ever had pretty
much single-handedly inventing the
splatter subg genre 1963's Blood Feast
and 1964's 2,000 Maniacs were orgies of
blood amputation and cannibalism and
despite their exceedingly cheap
production values and questionable
acting the movies were major Financial
successes Paving the way for the more
extreme gor flicks that were still yet
to
come it wasn't all guts and grew though
and actually a couple of the best movies
of the decade were classy old school
Ghost Stories 1961's the Innocence based
on Henry james' the turn of the screw
and 1963's The Haunting based on Shirley
Jackson's The Haunting of hillh housee
rung ample scares from shadowy
cinematography and spooky ambiguity
without showing anything overtly
frightening at all stately ghost stories
were also Making Waves in Japan and
worldwide with 1965's Quon even being
nominated for an Academy
Award Roger Corman also became a
prominent figure in horror in the early
to mid 1960s working with the smaller
Studio American International pictures
or
AIP Corman had started making lowbudget
films in the mid 1950s including several
westerns and teen fls
but he also made some Horror in sci-fi
including it conquered the world in
1956 attack of the Crab Monsters in 1957
and a bucket of blood in
1959 but in 1960 Corman would kick off
his most critically acclaimed series of
films with the first of his iconic Edgar
Allen Poe adaptations House of Usher
starring Vincent Price and with a
screenplay by famed horror scribe
Richard
mat seeking to compete with the gorgeous
Technicolor Gothic films beginning to
emerge from Hammer Corman would
ultimately direct seven more po
adaptations including the Pit and the
Pendulum from 1961 the premature burial
from
1962 Tales of Terror a 1962 Anthology
featuring four post Stories the Raven
from 1963 the haunted Palace which was a
1963 film that's considered part of the
post cycle even though in reality it's
an adaptation of HP lovecrafts Nolla the
case of Charles Dexter reward the mask
of the Red Death from 1964 and the tomb
of liia also from
1964 with the exception of the premature
burial which starred Ray Miland all of
the PO films featured Vincent Price in
the lead role some of the films also
brought back classic horror actors like
Boris carof Peter Lori and Lon Cheney
Jr back in Britain Hammer was getting
some more competition on its own turf
when upstart Studio Amicus Productions
began making horror films as well though
they sought to carve out their own Niche
by ising Gothic stories and going with
more contemporary Tales such as those
appearing in EC Comics or written by
Robert block author of psycho they
focused heavily on Anthology films such
as Dr terror's House of Horrors from
1965 and torture Garden from 1967 some
of which starred Hammer stalwarts
Christopher Lee and Peter Cushing but
they also made a handful of
straightforward horror movies like the
skull from 196 5 and the psychopath from
1966 in 1968 two momentous films were
released that would have a significant
impact on the genre going forward one of
these was Roman pansy's Rosemary's Baby
based on the bestelling novel by Ira 11
the film was the second in pansy's
Loosely themed apartment Trilogy the
first of which was the disturbing
psychological horror film repulsion from
1965 and the third of which was the
extremely unsettling Thriller the tenant
from
1976 Rosemary's Babies blend of satanic
themes paranoid horror and extremely
dark humor was a hit both with audiences
and with critics and paved the way for a
number of occult Focus horror movies in
the following
decade the other massively influential
movie that dropped in 1968 came from the
opposite end of the spectrum so to speak
whereas Rosemary's Baby was a major
Studio release from a respected European
director with a cast of well-known
actors Night of the Living Dead was the
very lowbudget independent debut of
Scrappy Pittsburgh filmmaker George A
Romero the movie shot in black and white
to keep cost low and featuring no known
actors was like a lightning strike to
the horror genre a terrifying and
gruesome Siege narrative that introduced
the current concept of the zombie to the
culture at large in one Fell Swoop
notable for its distressing violence
such as shambling ghouls clearly eating
people's body parts and a zombified girl
murdering her own mother with a garden
Trel the film also featured some
probably unintentional social commentary
in the form of its black hero all but
unheard of at the time being gunned down
by small town rednecks at the end after
being mistaken for one of the
zombies Night of the Living Dead remains
one of the seminal films in Horror
history as it established modern zombie
lore and spawned a sub genre so vast
that no matter your current age you
probably won't live long enough to watch
every movie about zombies that's been
made since
then a short list of more of my favorite
1960s horror films that I haven't yet
mentioned would include Mr
sardonicus Carnival of
Souls burn witch burn AKA Knight of the
eagle the birds Black
Sabbath Dementia 13 the film debut of
Francis Ford
Copa the last man on Earth an adaptation
of Richard mat's I Am
Legend Oni
Baba kill baby
kill
Persona The Fearless Vampire
Killers quater mass in the
pit the devil rides
out hour of the
wolf and witchfinder general aka the
Conqueror
worm
[Applause]
then came the 1970s which for my money
is still the best overall decade for
horror if the 1960s were all about
boundary breaking first the 1970s took
those initial seeds and grew all kinds
of interesting monstrosities in a number
of diverse Styles and
subgenres over in Italy the influence of
Mario bava's blood and black lace and
the popularity of the written mystery
stories and crime Thrillers of authors
like Edgar Wallace had initiated a
short-lived but mind-bogglingly prolific
boom in jallo films more than 30 of
which were made in the 1960s alone at
the start of the 1970s young filmmaker
Dario Argento crafted his debut film the
bird with a crystal plumage a stylish
murder mystery with a twisty plot and
some absolutely brutal kills and this
movie only accelerated Italian audien's
craving for these types of movies C
cusing an explosion that comprised
hundreds of films in the following two
decades Argento returned to the genre
three times in the 1970s releasing the
cat of nin tales and four flies on gray
velvet in 1971 and the awesome deep red
AKA profondo Roso in 1975 considered one
of the quintessential examples of the
form other notable directors of giali
included Sergio Martino who made the
strange Vice of Mrs Ward your Vice is is
a locked room and only eye of the key
and torso luchano eroli who made
forbidden photos of a lady above
suspicion death walks on high heels
death Walks at Midnight Umberto lenzi
who made paranoia Orgasmo so sweet so
perverse aload who made short night of
glass dolls and who saw her die and
Lucho fuli who made a lizard in a
woman's skin don't torture a duckling
and seven notes in Black aka the psychic
linday and fuli in particular would
become much better known in the United
States for their graphic Gore films
linday would go on to make the notorious
flicks eaten alive and cannibal farro
while fuli would become beloved as the
Godfather of Gore with his absolutely
stomach churning films Zombie 2 City the
Living Dead the beyond the house by the
cemetery and the New York
Ripper Mario Bava interestingly would
also make several more Gallo films in
the' 70s including Hatchet for the
honeymoon and five dolls for an aug a
moon but perhaps the most noteworthy of
these was his 1971 film a bay of blood
AKA twitch of the death nerve which was
a very obvious and enormous influence on
the slasher sub genre and featured two
scenes that were blatantly ripped off or
homaged in 1980s Friday the 13th while a
good argument could be made that psycho
or peeping Tom were technically the
first slasher movies a bay of blood in
my opinion is the first film that modern
audiences would unequivocally recognize
as a slasher as many of the later tropes
associated with the subg genre are
plainly evident such as killer POV shots
and the old sex equals death
situation back in the States the shock
waves from rosary's baby were still
being felt and the concept of exploring
a cult themed horror within a more
Prestige Hollywood framework produced
one of the Watershed films of the 70s
and the horror genre as a whole 1973's
The Exorcist adapted from a popular 1971
novel by William Peter blatty which was
Loosely based around the real Exorcism
of a young boy that took place in the
1940s the film was a cultural phenomenon
and ended up being nominated for 10
Oscars including best picture audiences
were stunned by the Grim realism of the
film and its willingness to completely
annihilate taboos the movie after all
very frankly showed an innocent
12-year-old girl getting possessed by
the devil and subsequently turning into
a foulmouthed vomit caked hellbeast who
not only masturbated with a crucifix but
then shoved her own mother's face into
her bloody vagina it was in modern
vernacular a
lot more satanic flicks followed in the
wake of The Exorcist such as Abby which
was a black sploitation take that came
out in
1974 Beyond the Door also from 1974 the
devil's reain from 1975 which had Anton
Le in it race with the devil from 1975
to the devil a daughter from 1976 and
The Omen also from
1976 other than the devil vampires were
also back in a big way in the
1970s in England Hammer brought Dracula
into the Modern Age with Dracula ad 1972
and satanic rights of Dracula which
featured Christopher Lee in his last two
appearances as the titular count
American director Bob kjan trod similar
ground with count yorga vampire from
1970 and the return of count yorga from
1971 Paul morisy an associate of Andy
Warhol made blood for Dracula in 1974
adding copious amounts of perversion and
Gore just as he had done for the
previous years flesh for
Frankenstein in a black exploitation
vein both blackula from 1972 and its
sequel scream blackula scream from 1973
were complete Aces and kicked off a bit
of a boomlet in Black sploitation horror
which included the not very good
blackenstein from 1973 and the actually
pretty awesome ganja and H also from
1973 later on in the decade Count
Dracula would Haunt movie screens once
again in a romantic 1978 adaptation of
Stoker's novel directed by John badham
and verer Herzog would release a remake
of NOS veratu in 1979 starring the
always off-putting K Claus kinsky as the
vampire
if the 1950s was somewhat known for its
radiation driven big bug films the 1970s
was likewise a decade of rampaging
creatures though in the latter case the
cause of the trouble was usually an
environmental pollutant of some kind
most likely spurred by the 1962
publication of Rachel Carson's
non-fiction work Silent Spring about the
dangers of chemical pesticides 1970s
Cinema saw all sorts of animals mutating
and growing enormous Andor super
agressive aggressive toward the humans
that had thoughtlessly [__] up their
habitats you saw killer rats such as
Willard from 1971 and Ben from 1972
giant killer bunny rabbits like in Night
of the lepus also from 1972 killer frogs
alligators birds and Butterflies from
the movie frogs also 1972 and killer
earthworms as in squirm from
1976 and in the midst of all this nature
takes Revenge brewhaha emerged a movie
that would not only be a massive hit
around the world but would also change
pretty much everything about the way
movies were released and marketed Steven
Spielberg's Jaws from
1975 though not really an Eco Horror in
the strictest sense since the great
white shark in Jaws was not obviously
affected by environmental factors and
was seemingly just an [__] the nature
runam Muk theme was still prevalent
throughout as was the message that
unfettered capitalism in in this case
keeping the beaches open despite the
shark attacks and failing to warn
swimmers about the gigantic and very
hungry Behemoth in the area could get
people
killed the movie holds up beautifully
nearly 50 years later and is a master
class in suspense building and effective
characterization famously the mechanical
shark Bruce not working all that well
and hence not appearing on screen as
often as was initially intended only
made the movie better as horror movies
are normally much scarier when the
monster still retains some
mystery while movie goers in the 21st
century have become accustomed to
massive tent pole films coming out in
the summertime there was actually no
concept of a summer blockbuster at all
prior to the release of Jaws movies just
came out whenever usually with no
consideration of their genre or budget
the summer debut of Jaws though was so
successful until the release of Star
Wars 2 years later it was the highest
grossing film of all time that it
changed the entire Hollywood model for
the release and marketing of
movies following the sensation caused by
Jaws knockoffs were inevitable 1976's
Grizzly was essentially Jaws but with a
pissed-off bear 1976's moo the jaws of
death was Jaws but with a different
species of shark 1977's Orca was Jaws
but with a killer whale and 1978's
piranha was Jaws but with piranhas not
to say that those films were bad they
were mostly pretty fun and I'd argue
that piranha actually flirts with
greatness having been directed by no
less a horror icon than Joe Dante Italy
also made some blatant cash grabs with
tentacles from 1977 about a giant
octopus great white aka the last shark
though that didn't come out till 1982
and monster shark AKA devilfish which
was directed by lamberto Bava and
featured a genetic hybrid between an
octopus and a prehistoric shark that
didn't come out until
1984 other Eco Horrors that turned up
later on in the decade included day of
the animals from 1977 Kingdom of the
spiders also from 1977 food of the Gods
1976 and Empire of the ants from 1977
both of which were based on works by HG
Wells then you had the Swarm from 1978
and Prophecy from
1979 the 1970s were also The Proving
Ground for upcoming young directors who
would contribute massively to the genre
going for forward Wes Craven burst onto
the scene with the absolutely merciless
Last House on the Left in
1972 an exploitation style take on ingar
bergman's 1960 film The Virgin Spring
Craven would later score another horror
hit with his second film 1977's The
Hills Have Eyes Loosely based on the
legend of Scottish cannibal Sonni bean
and his murderous
Clan Toby Hooper also cemented his
status as a master of the genre with the
hugely influential film The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre in
1974 despite its lurid title and subject
matter the movie is relatively free of
graphic Gore Hooper's genius was using
clever editing and misdirection to make
the audience think they saw a lot worse
[__] than what was actually there Texas
Chainsaw is a visceral experience
intense and revolting and makes you
genuinely glad that movies aren't shown
in smell a vision it also introduced
Leatherface a character who would become
one of the iconic faces carved onto the
Mount Rushmore of horror
villains 1976 saw the release of Brian
depalma's carry a brilliant and Darkly
funny adaptation of Stephen King's debut
novel about a ruthlessly bullied high
school girl who uses her burgeoning
psychokinetic powers to get revenge on
her
tormentors in 1977 was the year of Dario
argento's susperia a departure from his
previous Jello films in into the realm
of the fairy tale
Fantastical the movie one of the most
visually stunning ever made and modeled
somewhat after Snow White concerns an
American dancer who discovers that the
German ballet school she's attending is
a front for a coven of powerful
witches in 1978 another of the most
influential films in horror was released
one whose repercussions would be felt
for decades to come and whose success
would spawn a franchise that's still
going strong more than 40 years later
John Carpenter's Halloween had a
deceptively simple premise partly
inspired by films like psycho and Bob
Clark's black Christmas from
1974 admired in urban legends about
babysitters being stalked by Relentless
Killers Jam Lee Curtis's virginal lead
character Lorie Strode became the
Prototype of the final girl and the
actress herself was propelled to scream
Queen status particularly after starring
in several more horror films like the
fog prom KN night and Terror train in
the Years following the success of
Halloween she would also go on to
reprise her original role in a number of
sequels the film also gave us another of
the horror villain Hall of Famers in the
form of Michael Meers a silent hulking
Menace wearing an all-white mask that
was originally an altered mask of
William Shatner as Captain Kirk in the
first film a great deal of the
effectiveness stems from Michael's
creepy Stillness and indeed the original
intent of the character was to make him
essentially a blank slate a boogeyman a
personification of evil in the credits
of the original Halloween the Killer is
referred to only as the shape and Donald
Pleasant's character of Dr Lumis is
instrumental and conveying to the
audience how malevolent is the force
that animates his former patient later
films tried to mythologize Michael Myers
backstory and even give him blatant
Supernatural Powers but the original
film is still the scariest in my opinion
I because it left everything ambiguous
and didn't try to overe explain [__] I
hate it when movies do that in case you
couldn't
tell 1979 saw the release of the iconic
haunted house film The Amityville Horror
supposedly based on the true story of a
demonic haunting at the Lutz family home
which had previously been the scene of a
Multiple homicide carried out by Ronald
defo Jr who killed his entire family
with a shotgun and later blamed it all
on voices that part of the story is true
but whether or not the subsequent
haunting has any basis in reality is
entirely up to you to decide real or not
the film was undoubtedly effective Rak
in big box office and kicked off a
franchise that as of this writing
numbers more than 40 films though most
of them have nothing at all to do with
the original story and are just trading
on the Amityville name to low
audiences before the decade was out
there was just one more shot in the arm
to the horror genre one which saw the
scares coming not from knife wielding
weird Heros or Chomp happy sea creatures
but from the vastness of space Ridley
Scott's alien heavily influenced by
1958's it the Terror from Beyond Space
but most definitely its own distinct
thing hit theaters in
1979 and gave audiences their first
pants [__] look at one of the most
horrifying creatures ever put to film
The later named xenomorph designed by
eccentrics wi artist HR
Giger many critics have classified alien
as basically A Haunted House movie in
space which is true as far as it goes
much of the suspense is generated by
seeing these likable competent
characters being stalked through spooky
hallways by a monster whose full form
isn't revealed until well into the story
the movie also features one of the best
horror scenes and one of the best jump
scares of all time the sequence where
John ht's character Kane has a phallic
baby alien suddenly burst out of his
chest not only that but Al Al introduced
the world to easily one of the most
badass female characters in film history
siger Weaver Ripley a non-nonsense
warrant officer whose ass-kicking
awesomeness resides comfortably
alongside a deep nurturing compassion
that sees her rescuing the asomo cat
Jones from certain Doom a move which I
always really appreciated being a cat
lover myself alien is just a masterful
film by any metric is still scary and
effective today and is required viewing
for anyone one new to the
genre a grab bag of some of my other
favorite 7s horror movies that I haven't
mentioned so far would include let's
scare Jessica to death the blood on
Satan's
claw the Wicker
man don't look
now the Legend of Hell
House Black
Christmas Trilogy of
Terror God told me
to Burnt offer
Springs Invasion of the Body
Snatchers Salem's Lot and
fantasm some 70s era films from George
Romero and David Cronenberg would be on
the list too but I'll be discussing them
later when I get into talking about the
1980s and all the iconic horror
directors
[Applause]
individually the 1980s was an
interesting decade for horror generally
trading Less on the more Aur driven
films of the 1970s and focusing more on
low-budget gory lued flicks that would
appeal to Consumers of the burgeoning
Home Video Market the first horror film
to be released in the new decade as a
matter of fact was a Christmas slasher
to all a good night directed by last
house on the lefts David Hess the movie
wasn't all that good though and soon
became overshadowed by the Avalanche of
cheapy slashers that followed in the
wake of 1978's Halloween
speaking of which one of the most
influential of said cheapies was Shan s
Cunningham's Friday the 13th from 1980
unashamedly intended as a Halloween
ripoff but having its own scuzzy charm
that resonated hard with fans who made
it one of the longest running franchises
in
horror though to Alla good night got
there first even featuring a crazy Ralph
doomsaying character and the mother
killing and revenge for her child Trope
4 months before Friday the 13th Mrs
Vorhees Friday had the most staying
power cementing the hockey masked
machete wielding killer Jason Vorhees
who didn't actually get the hockey mask
until part three into the pantheon of
modern horror
villains many of the early 80s slashers
were forgettable quickies but fun for
their inventive kills and copious tits
and ass there were a few however that in
my opinion Rose above the rabble to
become something special these would
include Maniac from 1980 prom Knight
also from 1980 the burning from 1981 the
fun house also from 1981 that one was
directed by Texas Chainsaw Massacre
director Toby Hooper happy birthday to
me from 1981 My Bloody Valentine from
1981 those both were Canadian the
prowler from 1981 Sleepaway Camp from
1982 Superstition also from 1982
visiting hours also 1982 and Silent
Night deadly night from
the proliferation of violent slashers in
the80s as well as the import of some of
the gorier European exploitation films
that were holdovers from the 1970s
caused something of a moral Panic
particularly in the UK since at the time
the ability to rent movies on videotape
and watch them at home was very new many
of the titles available were unrated and
uncensored due to loopholes in the law a
uk-wide campaign led by Mary White House
was for a time a able to crack down on
so-called video nasties a list of 72
films deemed the worst of the worst by
largely clueless old fogies who had no
idea what they were looking at nor any
inkling why people watch horror movies
in the first place owners of video shops
had their products seized and a few even
went to jail simply for the crime of
renting out copies of the beast in heat
gestapo's last orgy or I Spit on Your
Grave for example obviously the
censorship rules were relaxed over the
ensuing years and most of the films
originally on the video nasties list
later became available without or with
minimal Cuts some of the movies on the
list were certainly graphic enough to
have drawn attention but the large
majority of them are laughably tame by
today's standards which makes the video
nasty Panic seem even funnier and sadder
in
hindsight many directors who got their
start in the 1970s continued in the
horror genre with great success in the
1980s the before mentioned Toby Hooper
who probably never again reached the
Perfection of the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre nevertheless hit the big time
in 1982 when he directed The Steven
Spielberg produced big budget horror
Extravaganza
Poltergeist though Hooper's other 8s
films such as 1981's the fun house
1985's life force and the 1986 horror
comedy The Texas Chainsaw Massacre 2
weren't as critically or financially
successful all of them are still great
and have developed a much oberved cult
following in the years since their
release Wes Craven started the 80s on
somewhat shaky footing releasing the odd
slasher deadly blessing in 1981 and the
mostly well-received but not explicitly
horror comic book adaptation Swamp Thing
in
1982 in 1984 though he struck Pay Dirt
crafting one of the most influential and
beloved films of the decade A Nightmare
on Elm Street taking the genius conceit
of mixing a TR traditional slasher with
dream based Supernatural elements that
would allow for all kinds of creativity
the movie was a massive hit and made an
instant star of its main villain Freddy
Krueger and the actor who played him
Robert
England like Friday the 13th A Nightmare
on Elm Street would spawn numerous
sequels as well as one crossover film
Freddy versus Jason from 2003 also a TV
series toys Comics video games and a lot
more though Craven wasn't able to replic
at the success of Elm Street for the
remainder of the decade I would
personally argue that his 1988 film The
Serpent and the rainbow Loosely based on
the non-fiction work by Anthropologist
Wayde Davis is one of his best films and
of course he would go on to change the
horror landscape once again in the mid
1990s with the release of scream which
we'll be discussing
later John Landis mainly known for his
1970s comedies Animal House and The
Blues Brothers dipped his toes into
horror comedy in the 1980s With An
American Werewolf in London a brilliant
1981 film whose werewolf transformation
scene designed and executed by special
effects Maestro Rick Baker still looks
jaw-dropping today and was rightly
nominated for the first ever Academy
Award for best
makeup American werewolf as it happened
was one of a mini trend of werewolf
films in the 1980s which also included
the excellent 1981 movie The Howling
directed by Joe Dante and with equally
awesome lycanthropes designed by Rob
botin whose special effects work will be
appearing again shortly he also had
1981's wolfin which was a crime Thriller
based on a book by Whitley streber
1984's the company of wolves a Gothic
horror fantasy directed by Neil Jordan
and 1985 Silver Bullet which was based
on the 1983 Stephen King Nolla cycle of
the
werewolf and speaking of Joe Dante he
would score another horror adjacent hit
in 1984 four with the spectacular
Gremlins a Christmas themed horror
comedy with superb creature Effects by
Chris Wallace who would also work on the
Fly which we'll be discussing in a
little while Gremlins was so successful
that it inspired its own MINI BOOM in
the small monsters run auk sub genre
with titles like Ghoulies from 1985
Critters from 1986 spookies also from
1986 munchies from 1987 and the Nader of
the trend the totally awful hob
from
1988 John Carpenter meanwhile was riding
high after the success of Halloween
which at the time was one of the most
lucrative Independent films ever made
though his 1980s movies weren't all
commercial successes and some were even
critically panned at the time of their
release which I have to admit boggles my
mind a bit every single one of them is
adored by most horror fans today and I
would submit that John Carpenter's
output over the entire decade
constitutes one of the best best if not
the best directorial hot streaks in
genre film
history in 1980 Carpenter chose to leave
behind the Lasher sub genre he'd helped
to popularize and went for a more old
school ghost story feel with the fog
about a strange Mist that descends on a
Seaside town and is eventually revealed
to contain the vengeful ghosts of
mariners getting back at the residence
for a wrong done to them a century
before he followed that up with the
absolutely cracking dystopic an
Adventure film escaped from New York in
1981 which introduced Kurt Russell's
iconic character snake pliskin To The
World At
Large then in 1982 Carpenter teamed with
Kurt Russell again and released what I
believe to be his magnum opus 1982's the
thing as I've already mentioned the film
was based on the 1938 Nolla who goes
there by John W cble which had
previously been Loosely adapted as the
thing from another world in
Carpenter's take on the thing was
stunning however a master class in
suspense building and claustrophobia
featuring amazing work by the
aforementioned Rob botin that really
blew the doors off as far as what could
be done with practical effects the thing
is easily in my top three horror films
of all time and I can't see any other
film dislodging it from its lofty perch
anytime
soon as for the rest of the 1980s
Carpenter kept the awesomeness flowing
with the solid 1983 adaptation of Ste
Kings Christine the 1984 sci-fi Love
Story Starman the immensely fun fantasy
action comedy Big Trouble in Little
China from 1986 the bizarre supernatural
horror film Prince of Darkness from 1987
and the paranoid SciFi classic they live
from
1988 not a bad run all things
considered Sam rayy though known
nowadays as a bigname director of tent
pole Marvel movies got his start back in
19 1981 with a modest little Cabin in
the Woods flick known as the Evil Dead
Shot for $90,000 at an abandoned house
in Tennesse the movie put Sam ry's
inventive Vision front and center
featuring peculiar camera angles
rudimentary but somehow endearing stop
motion effects a notorious incident of
tree rape and the indelible lead
performance of horror darling Bruce
Campbell the Evil Dead was a smash cult
hit making many times its budget back
and spawning a another wildly successful
franchise that seen sequels remakes
Comics merchandise and a terrific
three-season TV series starring Bruce
Campbell as the legendary Ash Williams
in 1987 Remy directed a sequel to The
Evil Dead which was essentially just the
first film remade with a higher budget
but absolutely no one
complained George Romero who had
single-handedly invented the modern
zombie subgenre back in
1968 spent the 1970s exper experimenting
with a few different things directing a
romantic comedy called there's always
vanilla in 1971 as well as a strange
drama called Season of the Witch in
1973 that same year he returned to
horror with the infection themed sci-fi
flick the crazies and released a subtle
psychological horror called the
amusement park in
1975 in 1977 he made one of my favorite
films of his the offbeat Vampire movie
Martin which starred John ampas as an
odd young man who believes himself to be
a vampire incidentally Martin marked the
first collaboration between Romero and
special effects Master Tom savini who
would go on to work on some of Romero's
most beloved
films when the director finally returned
to the zombie subgenre he created he did
so in a big way coming out with Dawn of
the Dead in 1978 which was a followup of
sorts to Night of the Living Dead
demonstrating how the zombie Menace had
spread throughout Society in the ensuing
decade the movie was a massive step
forward in terms of practical effects
with Tom savini and his then Protege
Greg nicaro who would of course go on to
found one of the most sought-after
effects companies in Hollywood knocking
it out of the park with copious amounts
of blood and viscera staining the screen
red Romero's 1980s output was equally
quirky commencing with the action drama
film Night Riders in 1981 but then
hitting tremendous Heights in 1982 with
the outstanding horror anthology film
Creep Show channeling the spirit of old
EC horror comics and based on original
EC inspired stories by stepen King Creep
Show was one of the most entertaining
horror comedies of the 80s and easily
one of the best horror anthologies ever
made every frame of it drips with love
for the
genre 1985 saw the release of the third
of Romero zombie films Day of the Dead
which amped up the gore exponentially
and features probably my favorite gag in
all of his films the character of RADS
getting torn in half by a gang of hungry
shamblers which is a showstopper of an
effect even today for the remainder of
the80s Romero stayed within the horror
genre directing the inferior but still
respectable Creep Show 2 in 1987 and the
sort of weird psychological horror film
monkey shines in
1988 Canadian body horror aour David
Cronenberg also got his start in the
1970s grabbing audien's attention with
his strange and grotesque offerings that
included Shivers from
1975 rabid from 1977 and The Brood from
1979 but in the early 1980s he became a
force to be reckoned with for American
Horror fans commencing with the bang of
an exploding head in 1981 scanners and
then unleashing the freakishly wonderful
sci-fi horror video drum in
1983 though the film was a box office
Failure Its themes effects and and
Direction were critically lauded and the
film became an influential Touchstone in
surrealist body
horror the rest of kimber's decade was
just as fruitful as he directed his own
masterful take on a Stephen King novel
The Dead Zone from 1983 an utterly
disgusting yet completely brilliant and
emotionally wrenching remake of a Cheesy
1950s classic the fly from 1986 which
would bring him the most mainstream
acceptance of his career and a
chillingly creepy psychological horror
about a pair of twin gynecologists and
their mutually assured destruction dead
ringers from
1988 Chicago born filmmaker Stuart
Gordon would come out of the gate
swinging in 1985 with his wildly
entertaining mad scientist film
reanimator Loosely based on an HP
Lovecraft Nolla with a heaping helping
of Frankenstein thrown in for good
measure the fun outreaches flick made
horror icons out of actors Jeffrey comes
and Barbara krampton and became one of
the most loved franchises in horror
fandom not least because of its
over-the-top Gore its pitch black humor
and one Infamous scene of a reanimated
severed head going down on a naked young
woman Gordon followed up the cult
success of reanimator with another loose
Lovecraft adaptation 1986's from Beyond
which brought back combes and krampton
in different roles and featur some great
special effects work and a cool
interdimensional premise though Gordon
would only direct one more horror film
in the 1980s the middling dolls from
1987 his frequent collaborator Brian
yuzna would Helm an awesomely bizarre
and sadly underrated body horror film in
1989 called society that almost has to
be seen to be
believed Tom Holland while perhaps not
quite the household name of some of the
other directors discussed so far is
responsible for directing two of the
best and most esteemed horror comedies
of the decade the incredible 19 1985
vampire film fright night about a high
school boy who suspects his swaave new
neighbor might be a blood sucker and
1988's Child's Play about a doll named
Chucky that becomes possessed by the
spirit of a serial killer and goes on a
rampage while fright Knight got a decent
sequel in 1988 and a remake in 2011
Child's Play became something of a
cultural Juggernaut followed up by six
sequels a TV series a remake Comics a
video game and loads of branded
merchandise the 1980s was also the
decade of Steven King the ridiculously
popular horror author was simply
everywhere with a dizzying number of
adaptations of his work as well as films
based on his original
screenplays the granddaddy of them all
of course was Stanley Kubrick's The
Shining from 1980 which Stephen King
famously hated but nonetheless remains
one of the best horror films ever made a
stone cold Masterpiece that took King's
excellent 1977 novel of the same name
about a haunted hotel and a boy with
psychic powers and turned it into a
chilling oppressive meditation on
familial breakdown that's so dense with
thematic resonance that there are
literally dozens of interpretations of
the movie's
symbolism out of all the films I've
discussed so far I think The Shining is
the one I've watched the greatest number
of times and it never fails to reveal
new layers upon every single revisit
that is a significant work of art
I've already mentioned a few of the
other king properties of the 1980s such
as Creep Show The Dead Zone Christine
Silver Bullet and Creep Show 2 but there
was also Kujo from 1983 Children of the
Corn from 1984 Fire Starter also 1984
cats eye an anthology film from 1985
standby me from 1986 that was based on
his novela called the body Maximum
Overdrive from 1986 Stephen King
directed this adaptation of his short
short story trucks and it's really
something there was also the Running Man
from 1987 and pet cemetery from 1989
film versions of King's work would
continue a pace into the
1990s another mini trend of the 1980s
was Nostalgia for the 1950s which was
seen across many forms of media not just
horror movies many horror directors
tried their hands at updates of 50s
films we've already talked about John
Carpenter's The Thing and David Kerber's
the fly but there was also the 1985 made
for TV remake of 1956's The Bad Seed
which had been based on a 1954 novel
Toby Hooper's 1986 Invaders from Mars a
remake of the 1953 film of the same name
Frank Oz's 1986 film adaptation of the
1982 Off Broadway musical horror comedy
take on 1960s Little Shop of Horrors and
Chuck Russell's excellent supremely gory
and criminally underrated 1988
reimagination of 1958's The Blob and
speaking of 50s Nostalgia there was also
a brief craze in the early 80s for 3D
movies examples included Friday the 13th
Part 3 from 1982 parasite also from 1982
Amityville 3D from 1983 jaws 3D also
from 1983 and Silent Madness from
1984 although Dracula and his ilk in
the80s were largely relegated to
comedies such as 1985's 1 bitten 1987's
my best friend is a vampire or 1988's
vampires kiss with Nicholas Cage or just
nastalgic horror comedies like 1987's
the Monster Squad some fantastic vampire
horror films came out during the decade
many of them inspired by the more
romantic or modern slant on the
creatures kickstarted by the novels of
Anne Rice we already mentioned Tom
Hollands 1985 fright night but 1983 saw
a stylish film adaptation of Whitley
streber novel the hunger directed by
Tony scottt and concerned with an
elegant thousands year-old female
vampire longing for a companion in 1987
Katherine Bigalow directed The excellent
vampire Western near dark and in the
same year Joel Schumacher would Helm
what is probably the quintessential 80s
vampire film The Lost Boys about a gang
of cool Teenage biker vampires menacing
a Seaside California
Town meanwhile over in Italy Dario arent
made Inferno in 1980 a followup to 1977
susperia and the second of his so-called
three mothers Trilogy which wouldn't see
completion until the release of the
sadly kind of awful mother of Tears in
2007 though Inferno couldn't top its
classic predecessor it had some stunning
visuals and an intriguing mystery that
made it worth watching the rest of Dario
argento's output in the 80s would be
somewhat sparse consisting of some real
gems like gofilms ten from 1982 and
Opera from 1987 and one interesting but
sort of odd paranormal film about a girl
who can telepathically communicate with
insects that would be phenomena from
1986 Argento would also serve as writer
and producer on a couple of fun
Supernatural Gore fests directed by
lamberto Baba demons from 1985 and
Demons 2 from
1986 Lucho fuli made a significant
impact with American Horror fans in the
1980s coming out strong with three of
his best loved films very early in the
decade the thematically linked Trilogy
of City the Living Dead from 1980 the
Beyond from 1981 which is probably his
best film and the house by the cemetery
also 1981 the dreamlike narratives and
revolting set pieces struck ACC chord
with a certain segment of the fandom and
earned fulie the nickname The Godfather
of Gore an appalachi previously bestowed
upon American splatter Pioneer herel
Gordon Lewis
F's subsequent films began to dip
somewhat in quality 1982's the New York
Ripper was pretty good if oddly mean
spirited but Manhattan baby from 1982
murder Rock from 1984 the devil's honey
from 1986 and Enigma from 1988
definitely showed some diminishing
returns a not so exhaustive list of some
of my other 80s favorites that I haven't
yet talked about would include Altered
States the
changeling dead and buried ghost story
The Hand Miz
possession Basket Case The Entity
Halloween 3 season of The Witch next of
kin Q the winged serpent
extro Twilight Zone The Movie KN of the
Comet the bride The Return of the Living
Dead a April Fool's Day Gothic Henry
portrait of a serial killer The Hitcher
house Angel Heart the Believers the gate
Hellraiser stage fright The Stepfather
killer clowns from outer space lady in
white The Lair of the White Worm Knight
of the Demons fantasm 2 pumpkin head
begot
the church parents and the woman in
black just the size of that list should
be some indication of how many great
horror movies came out in the
[Applause]
1980s and then came the
1990s don't get me wrong some classic
horror films came out during that decade
but in my view the 1990s was something
of a mixed bag and probably my least
favorite decade for horror movies
overall though the 2000s are also a
strong Contender the 9s didn't really
introduce any important horror directors
like the 70s and ' 80s had and a
depressing number of releases were just
inferior sequels to or remakes of
beloved older properties horror also
went meta and self-referential in the 9s
a trend that produced a handful of great
films and a shitload of insufferable
ones since I mentioned sequels for shits
and giggles let's take a look at a
sampling of the sequels that came out in
the year of 1990 alone the Amityville
curse Basket Case 2 bride of reanimator
Child's Play 2 Gremlins 2 the new batch
Leatherface The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
3 Maniac Cop 2 Predator 2 prom Knight 3
The Last Kiss Psycho 4 the beginning
Puppet Master 2 Silent Night deadly
night 4 initi initiation Slumber Party
Massacre 3 sorority house Massacre 2
Watchers 2 witchcraft 2 the temptress
and extro to the second
encounter one title you may have noticed
is conspicuously absent is the Exorcist
3 which I believe is a special case yes
it is technically a sequel to the
classic 1973 film and slickly pretends
that the laughably bad Exorcist to the
heretic from 1977 never happened but it
takes the story in a completely
different direction that almost succeeds
in making it a total Standalone less a
possession flick and more a supernatural
police procedural the movie features one
of the best jump scares in Horror
history and riveting performances from
both George C Scott and Brad dorf
Exorcist 3 is one of the rare examples
of a sequel done
right the first half of the 1990s seemed
to see an uptick in narratives based
around psychological horror and serial
killers almost as though filmmakers had
grown bored of the Paranormal excesses
of the 1980s and sought to ground their
Horrors more in the real world the
aforementioned Exorcist 3 followed this
trend as well as it centered on a
murderer known as the Gemini killer but
also featured demonic elements many of
these films were unequivocally horror
but straddled the line between horror
and Thriller thus making them more
palatable to mainstream
audiences the most successful of the
Thriller horror hybrids of the early
1990s was undoubtedly Jonathan Demi's
masterful 1991 film The Silence of the
Lambs an adaptation of the best-selling
1988 novel by Thomas Harris the film
follows FBI trainee Clarice Starling as
she attempts to glean information from
imprisoned serial killer and cannibal Dr
Hannibal Lecter to help catch another
serial killer named Buffalo Bill who is
still on the loose the film is one of
the most perfect Thrillers ever made and
and despite its horrific subject matter
was richly rewarded at the Academy
Awards picking up statues in all five of
the major categories including best
picture it was in fact the first horror
movie to win a Best Picture Oscar 1973's
The Exorcist had been nominated for best
picture but lost to the
sting later on in the decade David
Fincher's 7 from 1995 took the serial
killer Trope to even further extremes
and although the film is generally
classified as a time Thriller rather
than a horror movie there's no doubt at
all that the film contains some of the
most gruesome imagery and one of the
most effective jump scares in Horror
history in terms of psychological horror
there was 1990s Jacob's Ladder directed
by Adrian line a nightmarish exploration
of a Vietnam Veteran's fractured psyche
laced with conspiratorial distrust of
the government and packed to the gills
with terrifying hallucinogenic visuals
in the same year Joel SCH Shockers
flatliners saw an All-Star cast of hot
young actors portraying medical students
trying to figure out what lay Beyond the
Veil of death by essentially killing
themselves for longer and longer periods
before being
revived Stephen King adaptations also
continued at a decent clip into the
1990s and seemed to separate themselves
into three distinct strata brilliant
middling and turd sandwich in 1990 the
outstanding Anthology film from the Dark
Side of the movie featured a king Story
the cat from hell as one of its segments
and in the same year two adaptations
were released that exemplified the
Extremes in quality graveyard shift was
a middling to turd sandwich take on
King's 1970 short story about a crew of
workers encountering a shitload of rats
in the basement of a factory the movie
was only saved by an unhinged
performance by National Treasure Brad
Dorff on the opposite end of the scale
Rob riner's excellent misery starring
Kathy Bates and James KH is one of the
best psychological horror films ever
dealing with a romance novelist who
rescued from a car crash and
subsequently held captive by his insane
number one
fan brilliant 1990s King film
adaptations included Frank darabont's
Oscar nominated the Sha Shank Redemption
from 1994 Taylor hackford Dolores
Clayborn from 1995 and yet another Frank
Darabont at adaptation 1999's The Green
Mile as for middling films I would
nominate The Dark Half from 1993 Needful
Things also 1993 thinner from 1996 the
Night Flyer from 1997 an apt pupil from
1998 while scraping the bottom of the
barrel would be the baffling
Sleepwalkers from
1992 lawnmower man also from 1992 which
had absolutely nothing to do with the
original short story story it was
supposedly based on and had king's name
removed from the film after he sued and
The Mangler from
1995 I'll also note that a staggering
number of King Works were adapted for
television as well including it in 1990
the stand in 1994 and the langers in
1995 and King himself even wrote the
screenplay for a three episode
miniseries version of The Shining in
1997 which was directed by Mick Garris
the King was attempting to craft an
adaptation much closer to his Source
novel than Kubrick's acclaimed 1980
version in my opinion he pretty much
whiffed it sacrificing scares mood and
thematic depth for a twoo slavish
adherence to the plot beats of the book
The CGI effects were pretty cringey too
I have to
say British fantasy horror author Clive
Barker had burst onto the horror scene
in the 1980s with his utterly grotesque
books of blood and horror fans were
subsequently Blown Away by the visceral
and imaginative 1987 film Hellraiser
which Barker directed himself adapted
from his 1986 Nolla the Hellbound heart
prior to Hellraiser Barker had written
two films 1985's underworld and 1986's
rawhead Rex but was disappointed at how
the movies turned out leading to him
pushing to direct more of his own work
his 1990 film night breed based on his
1980 Nolla cabal was a box office
failure as was his 1995 film Lord of
Illusions but there was one adaptation
that was much more warmly received
though Barker didn't direct it 1992's
Candyman based on the short story The
Forbidden and directed by Bernard
Rose Candyman was a creepy Tale steeped
in urban legend focused on a graduate
student researching a frightening
legendary figure named Candyman played
by the unforgettable Tony Todd who is
supposedly haunting the crumbling Halls
of Chicago's Cabrini Green a notorious
housing project Candyman was an example
of another movie mini Trend in the 1990s
of urban horror or horror exploring the
gap between rich and poor and race
relations in the United States other
examples would include 1990s death by
Temptation West Cravens The People Under
the Stairs from 1991 and the 1995
Anthology film Tales from the
Hood
speaking of Wes Craven the man who had
already distinguished himself in two
decades was poised to make his Mark in
yet a third one being probably the
person most responsible for the rise of
metah horror in the latter half of the
'90s in 1994 he took the iconic
Boogeyman he' created in the 1980s
Freddy Krueger and went back to basics
attempting to make the character scary
again after a string of sequels had
turned him into something of a comedian
West Craven's New Nightmare Rec
contextual Iz the entire franchise
presenting a clever meta fictional story
about Wes Craven himself and all the
actors who had starred in the films all
playing themselves being terrorized by a
real Supernatural Boogeyman named Freddy
Krueger who had been conjured
inadvertently into the real world though
the film was the poorest performing of
all the nightmare films it was still a
box office success and only 2 years
later Craven would take a similar
formula and score a tremendous hit that
was not only financially successful but
culturally important influencing the
direction of horror for years to
come before then though John Carpenter
would also release his own take on meta
fiction but with a far more lovecraftian
flare 1994's in the mouth of Madness a
Trippy tale about an insurance
investigator who's on the trail of a
missing horror author named Sutter Kane
who may be able to write reality into
existence in 1996 West Craven dropped
another mic in the midst of horror media
in the form of scream which was
simultaneously an intelligent
entertaining slasher film and also a
self-referential satire of the very
genre it portrayed the fact that the
characters were media Savvy and knew all
the rules of previous horror movies was
somewhat novel and the film also had
some interesting things to say about the
perceived influence of horror movies on
real world violence and the way the
media exploits real life tragedies for
entertainment purposes
scream was a surprise success grossing
$173 million on a $15 million budget and
it not only led to several sequels and a
TV series but also kicked off a small
teen slasher Revival in the late 1990s
and early 2000s which included films
like I Know What You Did Last Summer
from 1997 which was based on a 1973 ya
novel by Lois Duncan there was also
urban legend from 1998 Cherry Falls from
2000 and Valentine from
2001 1996 incidentally would also be the
year of cult favorite the craft another
teen centered horror movie but one that
dealt with a covenant of high school
witches rather than knife wielding
Maniacs the classic Universal monsters
were also back in a big way in the 1990s
with Gothic horror seemingly skullking
back into fashion after a fallow period
in the
1980s in 1992 Francis Ford Copa released
his flawed but Majestic adaptation of
Bram Stoker's Dracula complete with
stunning period costumes a love story
based around the real historical figure
of Vlad the Impaler and an incredible
performance by Gary Oldman as the count
the success of Dracula led to several
more Gothic themed works and adaptations
including Interview with the Vampire
from 1994 based on the 1976 and rice
novel Mary Shell's Frankenstein from
1994 wolf from 1996 which was not
strictly Gothic but the the movie did
explore a more modern take on the
classic werewolf story Mary Riley from
1996 which was based on a 1990 novel by
Valerie Martin which was itself a loose
adaptation of Robert Lewis Stevenson's
The Strange Case of Dr Jackal and Mr
Hyde and Tim Burton's Sleepy Hollow from
1999 which was Loosely based on
Washington Irving's 1820 short story The
Legend of Sleepy
Hollow additionally in 1993 one of the
most prominent Gothic filmmakers of the
presid day would appear on the scene
Mexican aour Gayo Del Toro released his
debut the odd vampire film Kronos in
which an older man discovers an
alchemical mechanism that essentially
turns him into a blood craving creature
of the night who begins to fear that
he's becoming a danger to his beloved
granddaughter Asian horror also began
seeping into the Western horror
Consciousness in the late 1990s starting
with hideo Nika's ring from 1998 which
would explode into greater popularity
after gor verbinski helmed an American
remake of it in 2002 starring Naomi wats
other Asian films such as tekashi mik's
infamously disturbing audition from 1999
got great Word of Mouth among horror
fans though it should be noted that
Asian horror as a whole probably didn't
break through in a big way until the
early
2000s also in 1999 ight Shyamalan burst
onto the world stage with the wildly
successful ghost Story the six sense
whose twist ending was the source of
endless discussion and parody the six
sense was the second highest grossing
movie of the year after The Phantom
Menace and while there's no doubt that
it's an amazing film I've always been
more partial to another ghost story that
was released at almost the exact same
time and subsequently got forgotten in
the six senses long Shadow David kep's
Stir of Echoes Loosely based on Richard
mat's 1958 Novella the movie follows a
workingclass guide named Tom played by
Kevin Bacon who gets hypnotized at a
party and then begins having visions of
what seems to be a murdered girl it's a
creepy Supernatural murder mystery with
some great acting performances and
genuinely spooky imagery I always try to
recommend it when anyone asks me about
underrated horror
movies before the 1990s ended there was
one more bombshell on the horizon one
that would popularize if not invent an
entire subgenre of horror and serve as a
sterling example of successful early
internet marketing Daniel Myrick and
Eduardo Sanchez's The Blair Witch
Project was a found footage film made
for between $200,000 and $500,000 that
raked in nearly $250 million at the
worldwide box office and became a
cultural
phenomenon found footage wasn't a new
genre the 1980 Italian film Cannibal
Holocaust is widely considered the first
found footage horror film and there was
even a faux documentary called The Last
Broadcast that came out shortly before
Blair Witch in 1998 but the smash
success of Blair Witch directly led to
the proliferation of the subg genre in
the ensuing decades including the
equally lucrative Paranormal Activity
from 2007 which amped up the style even
more the fact that the filmmakers of
Blair Witch were Savvy enough to market
the film as though it was real footage
even setting up a website with
information about the missing characters
and making a separate documentary about
the legend at the heart of the story
lent the whole Enterprise and alternate
reality game feel which appealed to
users of early iterations of the
internet Blair Witch was massively
influential on horror at the turn of the
century but also quickly inspired
ripoffs and parodies of
Plenty to round out the decade let's
list a few of my favorite '90s horror
films that I haven't yet mentioned
Arachnophobia Franken hooker the
reflecting skin Tremors Cape Fear
subspecies Army of Darkness
brain dead AKA Dead
Alive Twin Peaks firew walk with me body
bags
Necronomicon Cemetery Man the addiction
Castle freak
copycat The Frighteners from Dust Till
Dawn Cube Event Horizon blade Bride of
Chucky and
ravenous
[Music]
as I mentioned a few moments ago The
Blair Witch Project was a huge influence
on the horror genre moving into the New
Millennium inspiring something of an
explosion in found footage films and
amateur media such as alternate reality
games and spooky YouTube series oddly
though for the first half of the 2000s
most of the movies that followed in the
wake of Blair Witch were parodies other
than the Blair Witch sequel Book of
Shadows Blair Witch 2 which came out in
2000 and technically wasn't a true found
footage film anyway there was the bogus
Witch Project the bear wench project the
Tony Blair Witch Project and the erotic
Witch Project among others additionally
The Meta horror Trend that had become
codified with the release of scream also
produced a flood of largely witless
horror parodies such as scary movie the
first one of which was released in 2000
it would eventually spawn four sequels
and shriek if you know what I did last
Friday the 13th also from
2000 in my view horror was going through
a slow evolution in the 1990s and 2000s
and The Meta horror boom was indicative
of larger media trends during that era
where the aim of horror was not
necessarily to scare you or disturb you
it wasn't cool or extreme to admit a
horror movie frightened you after all
you had to keep yourself at one ironic
remove from the material hence the glut
of parodies and horror that wasn't meant
to be taken
seriously please note that I have no
problem at all with horror comedies in
general and in fact count some of them
among my favorite horror films ever but
straight parodies have always fallen
pretty flat for me and I admit that I
largely prefer serious horror or at
least horror that is actively trying to
creep out provoke or otherwise unsettle
the viewer rather than trying to make
them laugh or feel clever about
recognizing horror
tropes happily the latter half of the
decade saw surge in more serious found
footage films particularly in the wake
of the enormously influential Paranormal
Activity from 2007 which was actually
fairly scary All Things Considered and
Harald did the rise of blumhouse a
horror production company we'll be
discussing more when we get to the
2010s the best of the late 2000s found
footage flicks would include the pypy
tapes from 2017 wreck also from 2007
Cloverfield from 2008 and Lake [__]
also from 2008 though that's more of a
mockumentary but still found footage
adjacent even some older franchises
attempted to stay relevant by releasing
found footage entries in this era such
as George a Romero's diary of the dead
from 2008 found footage would only
continue to grow and would produce many
more and even better entries in the
2010s the Remake Trend that had begun in
the 1990s really hit the gas pedal hard
in the 2000s so much so that it's the
overriding impression I get when I think
of horror movies released in that decade
there were new versions of House on
Haunted Hill 13 Ghosts Carrie The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre Willard Dawn of the
Dead toolbox Murders The Amityville
Horror the fog House of Wax Black
Christmas The Hills Have Eyes Night of
the Living Dead which had actually been
remade in 1990 directed by Tom savini
also the omen When a Stranger Calls the
wickerman Halloween The Hitcher the
wizard of Gore April Fool's Day Day of
the Dead long weekend prom night
Children of the Corn Friday the 13th
it's alive The Last House on the Left My
Bloody Valentine and house on Sorority
row though the remake of that which came
out in 2009 was just called Sorority
row there was also a new take on I Am
Legend in 2007 based on Richard Math's
1954 novel of the same name the story
had been adapted twice before as 1964's
the last man on Earth with Vincent Price
and 1971's the Omega Man with Charlton H
by the same token there was a fourth
version of Invasion of the Body
Snatchers released in 2007 simply titled
The Invasion the film was an adaptation
of the 1954 novel by Jack finny which
had previously been adapted in 1956 1978
and
1993 although the length of that list
would seem to imply that there was no
one making anything original in the
2000s
some big horror names were emerging that
would go on to produce influential work
in the genre going forward T West came
on the scene in 2005 with an independent
film called The Roost but really hit his
stride in 2009 with the release of
the80s satanic Panic throwback film The
House of the devil West would later go
on to further accolades with 2011's
Paranormal horror the inke keepers the
2013 found footage film The Sacrament
which was a reimagining of the Jim Jones
cult mass suicide and the 2022 onew
punch of retro slasher X and its prequel
Pearl both starring 21st century horror
darling Mia
goth additionally Australian filmmaker
James Juan got his start with the
unbelievably successful saw in 2004
which may have been the first volley in
the so-called torture porn Trend we'll
be discussing shortly and led to five
sequels just in the 2000s alone his
supernatural horror Dead Silence from
2007 was also pretty well received and
Juan would eventually achieve horror
Superstar status for inaugurating both
the Insidious and The Conjuring
franchises two of the most successful
horror film series of the 21st
century Eli Roth got his start in 2002
with the release of the successful
horror comedy cin fever and soon jumped
on the emerging torture porn train with
2005's hostile and its 2007 sequel the
much derided torture porn craze was
nothing new of course it was mostly
hearkening back to the sleazy
exploitation films in the 1970s but with
a 21st century sensibility much bigger
budgets and better special effects the
films undoubtedly made money so
filmmakers kept trying to push the
envelope musician Rob Zombie channeled
his love for trashy gory ultraviolent
horror flicks of old into his 2003 Film
House of a th000 corpses and then upped
the ante with its follow-up 2005's The
Devil's
Rejects the 2005 Australian film Wolf
Creek took the real life Backpacker
murders committed by Ivan mot and
Bradley Murdoch and distilled them into
the terrifying character of Mick Taylor
who brutally tortures three women over
the course of the film and in 2007
Austrian filmmaker Michael hanii
produced a shot for shot remake of his
own 1997 film funny games in which a
family is slowly tortured by two young
Psychopaths other similar films released
during this period would include
terorista in 2006 and the 2007 films
Borderland and captivity not to mention
the viscerally revolting 2009 film The
Human Centipede first sequence an
Infamous Dutch movie directed by Tom 6
which eventually spawned two sequels and
concerns a mad scientist who sews people
together mouth to
anus and speaking of torture it seems
that in the 2000s the French noticed
what was going on in the horror genre
and told the world to hold their cognac
the way of French horror films that
released in the 2000s were far more
Savage and disturbing than almost
anything Americans had seen and flew
under the flag of New French extremity
movies such as 2002's irreversible an
experimental rape Revenge film 2003's
high tension about a rampaging serial
killer 2007's inside about a pregnant
woman who has her home invaded by a
woman who wants to steal the baby from
her womb and 2008's Martyrs about a
young woman who seeks revenge on the
people who abused her as a child were
absolutely unflinching in their
portrayals of violence including graphic
depictions of rape evisceration and
every manner of abuse the trend also
extended to sex as some of the films
featured explicit scenes that bordered
on
pornography while France and the US were
trading in torture there was something
of a Mini Boom in British horror some of
it centering around zombie films which
took off in a big way in the 2000s Danny
Bo's EXC excellent 2002 film 28 Days
Later which popularized fast-moving
zombies that were actually living people
infected with a virus that caus him to
go crazy and 2004's delightful zombie
comedy Sha of the Dead directed by Edgar
Wright helped to get the zombie ball
shambling as it were as did the American
Zack Snider's popular 2004 remake of
George Romero's Dawn of the Dead by the
end of the decade in terms of zombies
the Resident Evil franchise had three
films under its belt which would add
three more films in the 2010s and a
reboot in 2021 George Romero added three
more entries to his iconic Zombie series
and other films like pho from 2006 28
Weeks Later from 2007 Pony pool from
2008 Dead Snow from 2009 and Zombie Land
also from 2009 would flood the horror
landscape with flesh eating ghouls of
all different
kinds two other beloved British films of
the 2000s included the awesome 2002
British Army fighting werewolves movie
dog soldiers and the claustrophobic
nightmare of 2005's The Descent about a
group of cavers who become trapped in a
series of tunnels and are set upon by
horrific
creatures Mexican filmmaker gamer Del
Toro who had thrown his horror hat into
the ring with the 1993 vampire film
Kronos made a somewhat big budget sci-fi
horror called mimic in 1997 but in 2001
returned to his Indie Spanish language
roots with the brutal and eerie ghost
story The Devil's Backbone set during
the Spanish Civil War two more Hollywood
films followed Blade 2 from 2002 and
Hellboy from 2004 but then Del Toro
crafted what I believe to be his
Masterpiece 2006's dark fairy tale Pan's
Labyrinth in which a little girl During
the francoist period in Spain discovers
a hidden world of fairies and magical
creatures including a mysterious Fawn
and an absolutely terrifying character
called The Pale Man Who has his eyes and
the palms of his hands rather than on
his
face if 1998's ring foreshadowed the
Asian horror Renaissance to come then
the trend would reach full flower in the
early 2000s producing exceptionally
creepy works like the 2002 Hong Kong
Singaporean film The ey which got an
inferior American remake in 2008 hideo
nad's 2002 Dark Water which got a decent
American remake in 2005 and tekashi
shitzu 2002 Jew on The Grudge which got
a middling remake in 2004 that was just
called The Grudge there were many other
Stellar Asian horror films released
during this decade such as Battle Royale
from 2000 pulse from 2001 one miss call
from 2003 A Tale of Two Sisters also
from 2003 and shudder from 2004 several
of these also got English language
remakes including pulse remade in 2006
one miss call remade in 2008 A Tale of
Two Sisters remade in in 2009 as The
Uninvited and shudder remade in 2008
though in nearly all the cases listed
above I would argue that the Asian
Originals of the films listed are
superior to their later American
counterparts I will admit that I believe
the sole exception to the rule is gor
rinsky's 2002 remake of the Ring which I
liked much better than the 1998 Japanese
original feel free to disagree but the
original ring just gave me mild heebie
GBS while the American version of the
Ring scared the absolute crap out of me
and gave me nightmares for several days
afterward more of my favorite films from
the 2000s that I've yet to mention would
include American Psycho Final
Destination Ginger Snaps shadow of the
vampire Brotherhood of the wolf
Deon from Hell Jeeper Creepers malland
Drive the others session N9 Bubba hotep
May dead end The Exorcism of Emily Rose
the skeleton key behind the mask the
rise of Leslie Vernon cold prey Slither
30 Days of Night
1408 The Girl Next Door the Mist the
orphanage the signal teeth trick-or
treat windchill the children Eden Lake
I sell the dead Let the Right One In The
Midnight Meat Train The Ruins Splinter
The Strangers all about evil
Antichrist The
Collector Drag Me to Hell Jennifer's
Body the loved ones orphan Pandorum and
triangle
overall thankfully the 2010s seemed to
start moving in a much more interesting
and serious Direction in terms of horror
movies in many ways recalling the more
experimental and cerebral filmic
landscape of the 197s and early
1980s in spite of this General tendency
however we did still get a shitload more
remakes in that decade though happily
not as many as we saw in the 1990s and
2000s there were for example new
versions of the crazies I SP on Your
Grave a nightmare in Elm Street Fright
Night Maniac Evil Dead the town that
dreaded Sundown Poltergeist Cabin Fever
flatliners Black Christmas and Child's
Play just to name a few there were also
a handful of American remakes of foreign
films such as let me in a 2010 English
language version of the 2008 Swedish
film Let the Right One In and a 2016
American reboot of the heroing new
French extremity classic
murders in 2018 Luca guadino had the
stones to craft a 21st century version
of Dario argento's iconic 1977 susperia
but changed the look in story so much
that it barely qualified as a remake
though I must admit I loved it anyway as
I felt it was the only way you could do
the original Justice save for not
remaking it at all in 2012 we also saw a
bigger budget version of The Woman in
Black which was based on Susan Hills
1983 Gothic novel but had been adapted
to film once before in 1989
there were still some torture porn
stragglers in the 2010s as well and as a
whole the decade seemed pretty
comfortable with ridiculous levels of
Gore and disturbing content the
notorious ass Serbian film was released
in 2010 and is still considered by many
to be the worst of the worst as far as
vile content goes in addition 2016 saw
the popularization of a new horror icon
art the clown in the ultra gory
terrifier though thect character had
actually first been introduced in the
2013 horror Anthology all Hollows Eve
the sequel terrifier 2 was released in
2022 and increased the gore level
significantly though it was still a
pretty fun flick all around if a touched
too
long one of the biggest success stories
of the decade was horror production
company blumhouse which rocketed into
the public Consciousness in7 with their
release of the massively lucrative
Paranormal Activity and went from
strength to strength as the years went
on their very profitable business model
was predicated on producing small to
moderately budgeted films giving
directors the freedom to make what they
wanted and then getting the films into
wide release through the bigger
Hollywood studio system using this
method they absolutely dominated the
multiplex horror market with the
excellent and wildly popular films
Insidious from 2010 and Sinister from
2012 Insidious would later boast four
sequels and Sinister would receive one
in
2015 blumhouse was responsible for
producing far too many films to list but
one of the other successful properties
they distributed was The Purge the first
installment of which was released in
2013 the franchise would eventually
comprise four additional films and a TV
series James Juan who got a start in the
mid 2000s with saw and was also
responsible for the aforementioned
Insidious films made an even bigger
Splash with 2013's The Conjuring a
creepy supernatural horror Loosely based
on the supposedly real paren family
haunting from the
1970s the film introduced Patrick Wilson
and Vera figa in their recurring roles
as real life demonologists Ed and
Lorraine Warren and several more
interconnecting films would follow in
subsequent years all of them part of the
sprawling Conjuring Universe the first
of these to be released following the
success of The Conjuring was 2014's
Annabelle based on a reportedly true
story of a possessed or haunted doll and
later films included the The Conjuring 2
from 2016 Annabelle creation from 2017
the nun from 2018 Annabelle comes home
from 2019 The Conjuring the devil made
me do it from 2021 and the nun too from
2023 another significant Trend in the
2010s was the rise of so-called elevated
horror a controversial term that simply
referred to movies that were more
focused on character development
psychological horror the building of
atmospheric dread and sometimes
metaphorical themes films of this
description had been appearing since the
silent era and indeed many of the films
we've been discussing this entire time
would likely fall into this category but
the style was back in a big way in the
2010s and got loads of thoughtful media
attention the first two widely talked
about films associated with the elevated
horror tag were probably the Australian
film the Boba du from 2014 directed by
Jennifer Kent and focused on a widowed
single mother and her son who seem to
become the target of an unsettling
monster from a children's book and David
Robert Mitchell's it follows also from
2014 a heroing film about an
everchanging Supernatural entity
invisible to everyone but the victim
that's passed from person to person
through sexual intercourse both movies
were wonderfully scary in their own
right but also sparked spirited
discussions about the metaphorical
meanings of their respective
antagonists independent studio a24 is
also usually brought up in tandem with
this trend founded in 2012 they weren't
initially focused on horror though they
did release works like Den villanu
surrealist psychological horror film
enemy and Jonathan Glazer's bizarre
sci-fi film Under the Skin in
2014 but in 2015 the company Drew genre
fans attention when they Unleashed
Robert Edgar's brilliant folk horror
film The Witch a critical and financial
success that suggested horror fans were
open to more intellect ual Slow Burn
Fair along these lines a24 would also
release Ari Aster's 2018 debut
hereditary a densely layered and
stunningly acted work about a grieving
family who seemed to be tormented by a
demonic cult associated with the
deceased grandmother in my view
hereditary is unquestionably one of the
best horror films of the 21st century
and made me feel things that a horror
movie hadn't made me feel since I was a
child though brilliant the film was so
anxiety inducing for me that it took 2
years for me to gather up the courage to
watch it for a second time AR Aster's
second film a broad daylight folk horror
freakout called midamar from 2019 was
equally incredible though completely
different than hereditary the only
similarities being the focus on loss and
the mind-boggling array of complex
background detail that filled in the
rich universe of the story without overt
exposition
Jordan Peele who got his start in comedy
was another filmmaker closely associated
with the elevated horror wave in 2017
his directorial debut get out wowed
critics and audiences alike with its
disquieting and satirical take on a
post-racial America filtered through a
tone reminiscent of Ira levans The
Stepford Wives get out was one of the
few horror movies to be nominated for a
Best Picture Oscar as well as best
director and best actor though in the
end Peele only won for best original
screenplay his 2019 followup us was less
praised but still outstanding a story
about Creepy doppelgangers that also
served as a metaphorical examination of
the American underclass and the gap
between rich and
poor other elevated horror films of the
decade would include Julia doral's raw a
2016 film that could also fall into the
extreme horror category Darren aronowski
mother from from 2017 John kosinski's a
quiet place from 2018 Robert Edgar's the
lighthouse from 2019 and Rose glasses St
mod also from
2019 perhaps due to the cultural
ubiquity of the 80s set Netflix series
stranger things and the internet
proliferation of vapor wave and the
visual style known as hauntology horror
movies that were set in or mimicked the
aesthetic of the 1980s were also
plentiful 2018 summer of ' 84 went
literal with it presenting an almost
spielbergian tale of a group of
teenagers who suspect that their
neighbor might be a serial killer while
films like Joe vos's Bliss and VFW both
from 2019 were set in the present day
but wallowed in saturated neon lights
and John Carpenter esque
touchstones on a related note there was
a mini Trend in movies based around' 60s
and' 7s psychedelia and acid trippy
visuals where the plot was secondary to
the drug fueled color melting Madness
films of this ilk would include 2012's
Beyond the Black rainbow and 2019s Mandy
both directed by AOS Cosmos and Gaspar
no's Climax from
2018 some of these types of movies also
had a lovecraftian cosmic horror flare
such as the void from 2016 Annihilation
from 2018 and color out of space a 2019
adaptation of an actual ual Lovecraft
story other trippy retro or experimental
films from this era that I would
recommend include Barbarian Sound Studio
the editor the love witch the neon demon
the killing of a sacred deer in fabric
antrum the deadliest film ever made and
wounds David Cronenberg who had strayed
somewhat away from Horror in the 1990s
and 2000s helming more dystopian sci-fi
tinged works like 1996's crap crash an
adaptation of the 1973 JG Ballard novel
and 1999's existen or crime Thrillers
such as 2005's a history of violence and
2007's Eastern Promises wouldn't delve
back into the body horror that made his
name until 2022 Crimes of the future
however his son Brandon Cronenberg
proudly picked up the body horror mantle
directing his own disturbing works such
as antiviral from 2012 about a future
where people can choose to pay to be
infected Ed with illnesses from adored
celebrities and possessor from 2020
about an assassin who can possess other
people's bodies in order to discreetly
carry out her deadly assignments Brandon
kenberg also made the brilliant infinity
pool in 2023 a bizarre film starring
Alexander Skarsgard and Mia goth about a
couple at an island resort who discover
some very strange goings on with the law
after the husband accidentally killed
someone in a car
accident there were also a handful of
great found footage movies and
mockumentaries released in the 2010s as
the subgenre widened its focus and
experimented with new ideas Andre
avdol's troll hunter from 2010 was
particularly delightful centered around
a man who's paid by a secret government
agency to keep gigantic trolls in Norway
from rampaging around and making
themselves known to an oblivious public
other notable found footage movies of
the decade included Grave Encounters
from 2011 the Bay from 2012 VHS the
initial 2012 Anthology would eventually
spawn five further films a miniseries
and two spin-off films it was also as
above so below from 2014 The Taking of
Deborah Logan also from 2014 and creep
also from 2014 and its sequel creep 2
from
2017 as people lived more and more of
their lives online horror stepped up to
reflect fears endemic to the internet
era and the proliferation of social
media producing films like like Megan is
missing unfriended # horror friend
requests tragedy girls like me selfie
from Hell unfriended dark web and two of
my particular favorites Cam and the
cleansing
hour Universal Studios in an effort to
bring some of their iconic properties
into the modern era and rake in the same
kind of cash as Marvel had managed to
with their sprawling expanded universe
envisioned what they called The Dark
Universe a proposed series of
interconnected movies utilizing the
classic Universal monsters on its face
this sounded like a pretty cool idea but
from the beginning there were issues for
example in 2010 there had already been a
modern Take On The Wolf Man starring
Bono Del Toro which had been a box
office bomb even though I admit I kind
of liked it in 2014 Dracula Untold An
Origin story for the count based Loosely
on Vlad the Impaler was released and did
quite a bit better but was later
discounted as part of this hypothetical
Dark
Universe the first film in this new
series was set to be 2017's the mummy
which was promoted out the Wazoo and
thought to be a sure thing due to the
Blazing star power of Tom Cruz although
the film did end up grossing more than
$400 million worldwide it was still
considered a failure due to the
ridiculously high production and
marketing costs critics weren't kind
either comparing the film unfavorably
with the much more fun Brendan Frasier
mummy movie from 1999 and lamenting its
lack of originality and a muddled plot
that seemed overly focused on trying to
set up the extended Universe characters
reaction to the film was so negative
that Universal scrapped the entire Dark
Universe idea deciding instead to Simply
make Standalone movies based around the
monsters that didn't have anything to do
with one another the first of these
2020s The Invisible Man was written and
directed by James Juan's frequent
collaborator Lee wanell of Saw and
Insidious Fame and was a Smash Hit
drawing loads of critical praise and
grossing $145 million worldwide against
a $7 million budget let horror people do
horror Universal that's the lesson
there guer m Del Toro spent the first
half of the decade working on another
big budget action film 2013's giant
robot epic Pacific Rim but afterward he
returned once again to the gothic genre
that was his first love directing the
visually stunning Crimson Peak in 2015
then releasing his own romantic take on
the Creature from the Black Lagoon
2017's the shape of water which won the
Oscar for Best Picture Del Toro also
wrote and produced Andre aol's 2019
scary stories to tell in the dark and
Anthology film based on the ya book
series and in 2022 would oversee the
enjoyable Netflix horror Anthology
series G model Toro's Cabinet of
Curiosities the increase in the number
and reach of streaming options during
the 2010s and specifically the founding
of horror specific platforms like
shudder was likely a big factor in the
parallel increase in the popularity of
the horror genre as a whole no longer
did you have to venture out to the
theater to see one of maybe a handful of
bigger budget horror movies that
actually got a wide release now you
could sit on your couch and have
literally thousands of horror movies
from all eras and budgetary levels right
at the tips of your
fingers this seismic shift in the manner
in which entertainment was dispersed to
the public not only helped indie horror
filmmakers get their work in front of
more eyes but also made a lot more
foreign horror easily accessible for
anyone who wanted to see it for example
the outpouring of love for the
frenetically entertaining and
heart-wrenching South Korean zombie film
trained to Busan from 2016 was partly
due to its ready availability on so many
American streaming platforms other
foreign films that garnered a great deal
of buzz from English-speaking horror
fans for the same reason included the
Wailing from 2016 from South Korea Basin
also from 2016 from Turkey terrified
from 2017 that was from Argentina tigers
are Not Afraid from 2017 from Mexico
Veronica 2017 from Spain and Satan's
slaves 2017 from
Indonesia one individual who arguably
benefited a great deal from the rise in
streaming horror was filmmaker Mike
Flanigan though he gained the most
public attention with his insanely
popular Netflix series The Haunting of
Hill House in 2018 Loosely inspired by
Shirley Jackson's classic 1959 novel of
the same name he' actually had quite a
few acclaimed horror films under his
belt before that including Absentia from
2011 Oculus from 2014 hush from 2016 and
Ouija origin of evil also from
2016 Mike Flanigan would go on to direct
two Stephen King adaptations 2017's
Gerald's Game and 2019s Dr sleep a
sequel to The Shining before returning
to Netflix to produce several more
successful horror series such as 2020s
the haunting of blind Manor which was
Loosely based on Henry james' 1898
novela the turn of the screw 2021s
midnight mass an original story about
supernatural events plaguing a small
island Community after the arrival of a
mysterious priest and 2023 is the Fall
of the House of Usher a sprawling family
tale inspired by several Edgar alanos
stories other than Mike Flanigan several
other directors released their own
Stephen King adaptations in the 2010s MC
Garis gave us bag of bones in 2011 while
yet another version of Carrie directed
by Kimberly Pierce was released in
2013 2014's Mercy directed by Peter
Cornwell was a loose adaptation of
King's short story grma while Todd
williams' cell from 2016 was based on
King's 2006 novel of the same name
Netflix gave us Zack hild's 1922 in 2017
and Vincenzo Natali in the tall grass in
2019 while Kevin kulch and Dennis
whitmire's pet cemetery hit theaters in
March of
2019 as far as Stephen King Properties
went however the biggest success story
of the decade by far was the two
installment adaptation of it the first
part of which was released in 2017 and
focused on the first half of King's epic
1986 novel the new iteration of the
terrifying Pennywise the Dancing Clown
played by Bill scarg guard became an
instant cultural phenomenon and one of
the most popular Halloween costumes that
year 2019 it chapter 2 while not quite
as positively reviewed still made
buckets of dough both films together
raked in over a billion dollars
worldwide not too shabby for a scary
movie about a murderous shape-shifting
clown films from the 2010s that I loved
but haven't discussed so far would
include Black Swan Frozen The Last
Exorcism The Reef Tucker and Dale Versus
Evil we are what we are you're next The
Cabin in the Woods
excision John Dies at the End the packed
would you rather Only Lovers Left Alive
the canal a girl walks home alone at
night
good night mommy housebound Starry Eyes
Tusk what we do in the shadows the black
coat's daughter the gift Krampus Maggie
Tales of Halloween the invitation the
autopsy of Jane Doe don't breathe I am
the pretty thing that lives in the house
the babysitter the ritual possum unsane
upgrade the hole in the ground and ready
or
[Applause]
not it's now the end of 2023 as I record
this and it's probably too early in the
decade to determine what new directions
if any the horror genre will take going
forward obviously horror has been
affected by the covid-19 pandemic as has
every other aspect of people's lives
individuals confined to their homes for
long stretches of time tend to watch a
lot of streaming media after all and for
a significant percentage of those people
the anxiety of the outside world draws
them to watch more horror though the
pandemic disrupted the film industry in
ways that will likely never be
completely mended such as the now fairly
common practice of releasing films
nearly simultaneously in theaters and on
streaming platforms some filmmakers
decided to take advantage of the
limitations imposed on them and make
something that would serve as something
of a time capsule of this tumultuous era
probably the best known film completely
produced during lockdown was 2020s host
a decently creepy British found footage
film that takes place entirely during a
seance conducted via Zoom call the movie
dropped on shudder in the summer of 2020
and immediately found an appreciative
audience other smaller films that
attracted a great deal of attention due
to their popularity on various streaming
platforms included the Taiwanese
bloodbath the sadness from 2021 the
Killer Android film Megan from 2022 the
experimental analog horror Skinnamarink
also from 2022 the Eerie psychological
horror smile from 2022 the contacting
the dead horror talk to me 2022 Ari
Aster surrealist tragic comedy Bo is
afraid from
2023 the spooky monster horror cobweb
from 2023 the Alien Invasion horror no
one will save you 2023 and the fun
throwback slasher totally killer also
from
2023 another film that Drew massive Buzz
both during its theatrical release and
its subsequent premiere on streaming was
Zach craiger's utterly Bonkers and
exceptionally awesome barbarian from
2022 a movie that wasn't afraid to go in
completely unexpected directions and
trusted its audience to keep up with its
wild ballsy
twists internet and social media based
horror also continued on a
with many of the films focusing on
people doing horrible things for likes
and follows some of the better movies in
this vein included spree dash cam we all
going to the World's Fair bodies bodies
bodies and
deadstream there were also a few
lingering remakes in the early 2020s
though it would seem the trend might be
petering out we did however see new
takes on The Grudge Candyman Slumber
Party Massacre Wrong Turn fire starter
good night Mommy and
Hellraiser in 2020 there was also yet
another adaptation of the turn of the
screw simply called the turning which
was mostly disappointing and unnecessary
in light of Mike Flanigan's looser but
much better Netflix mini series based on
the same
work the last few years have also seen
largely successful and fairly big budget
reboots or continuations of decades old
franchises the Halloween series
continued on from the 2018 sequel which
was just called Halloween confusingly
with Halloween kills in 2021 and
Halloween ends in
2022 in addition scream got a fifth
installment in 2022 which again was just
called scream even though it was a
direct sequel to 2011's Scream 4 Evil
Dead rise Insidious The Red Door saw X
and The Exorcist believer were the other
hyped installments in their respective
franchises the reviews of all of them
were somewhat
mixed a list of films that have come out
in just the past four years that I
haven't mentioned yet but would
recommend would include the babysitter
Killer Queen the dark and the wicked
rentapal
underwater censor come true coming home
in the dark in the earth Jacob's wife
lamb last night in
SoHo malignant the black phone the deep
house the nighthouse to 10 we need to do
something Willy's Wonderland a wounded
Fawn fresh speak no evil Watcher the
last Voyage of the demer and when evil
lurks I hope you've enjoyed coming with
me on this journey through Horrors
highways and byways and I hope that you
will continue to travel along with me as
we take the genre into the future and
Beyond I'll see you guys again on the
next
[Laughter]
[Music]
one